in terms of Big Ideas I think that I
think that there's a another revolution
coming I'm not sure what it's gonna look
like but I think it's gonna be very
interesting and it's gonna unfold over
the next 10 years and I think it needs
to be a spiritual revolution because I
think that our systems are broken I
don't think that our political system
will ever work I don't think how no
matter how great a man if you cloned JFK
and Abraham Lincoln and made them
president it wouldn't matter
our system is just too corrupt and too
broken I think that science is corrupt
and broken I think health and nutrition
I think the economic systems the
international relations the environment
everything the engines of everything are
broken there's some good ideas there
behind and some good intentions but
these are gonna break down more and more
and more we're gonna see these wild
pendulum swings between you know
Democrat Republican Tea Party right-left
right-left is going to swing every
election because people are scrambling
for answers and it just it doesn't work
so the young people are gonna need to
like they did in the 60s they're going
to need to take the reins here and
really look at the world in a fresh new
way and say you know enough is enough
you guys you guys screwed it up we need
to take our our planet back and I think
part of that journey part of that
revolution needs to be spiritual I think
that the word spiritual is very loaded
weird word but I think it needs to be
with a heart based wisdom and this heart
based wisdom needs to go hand in hand
with science and with social activism
and love for our planet and love for our
whole human family that spans the whole
globe and this may sound very high and
mighty or airy-fairy but it's gonna have
to go to that or else we're just all
gonna destroy
there